(audience cheering and clapping)
- Give it up!
Have a seat.
(audience yelling and clapping)
Give it up, give it up.
This is exciting today, in five seasons,
this has never happened.
We have had rowdy audiences,
but in five seasons,
you win.
- [Olivia] Oh man.
- That is, you all get an award.
That was insane.
Congratulations on all the Grammy noms.
- Oh, thank you, thank you.
(audience cheering)
It's gonna keep happening.
- Well, congrats on
yours too, it's amazing.
- I was telling, I was
telling her backstage,
I was telling her
backstage, the win for me
is literally who I'm nominated with.
Like that's the win for me.
I was telling her, like I always see like
who's in the same category,
and I'm like (gasps).
And everybody is so good.
- Yeah.
- In the category we're both in,
I was like oh my god, so
that's the win for me.
- Yeah, it's so...
- To be like amongst your peers
that you're just like oh my god.
- [Olivia] Yeah.
- Like those are people
I would collaborate with,
I listen to, I love, like
that's the win for me.
- It's so nice to be like included
in such a wonderful group of people.
- Yeah, absolutely.
What, I don't know, what's
your most meaningful nom?
Was it your first one?
That was for "Sour", that record.
- Yeah, yeah, I got nominated
for "Sour", which was so cool.
This year I actually got
nominated for best rock song
for "Ballad of a Homeschooled Girl".
(audience cheering)
Which is so cool.
- That's an amazing thing.
I hear on your, so on tour you saw me,
or they're right here.
They're in-ears, we call them in-ears,
but you can decorate them.
And I go gold sparkly seventies.
- [Olivia] Cute.
- But you have photos on yours.
I didn't know you could do photos.
- Yeah, you can put photos.
- No one told me this.
- Yeah, you put photos of your
kids, put photos of anyone.
Those are mine.
- [Kelly] Edward Cullen.
- That's my, that's my baby.
Like, that's my thing.
- I'm a "Twilight" nerd.
- That's Edward Cullen on my in-ears.
(audience cheering)
He is my...
- The purple lavender,
I like it too, yeah.
- Yeah, he's my guiding light on tour.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I have to have my lucky charm.
Yeah, love him.
- What's on your in-ears now?
- My in-ears now for this Guts tour,
I'm gonna get a new face every tour,
so taking suggestions for the next one.
Maybe I'll put you on my next one.
- Okay, aim for like something random.
Like Betty White, like just
something random, right?
- Yeah, but this year it's um.
- It makes you happy.
- Totally.
- Oh, it's Kim Cattrall.
- Yeah, it's Kim Cattrall.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I love that.
- It's Kim Cattrall
from "Sex in the City",
Samantha from "Sex in the City".
She's my favorite, and she's
like drinking a little martini,
and I thought it was great.
- Why not.
- [Olivia] Why not.
- You know what, that's says celebrate,
every time you put your
in-ears in, I like it.
- Yeah, uh huh.
- I think I did know you could do photos.
Do you have Rue?
Do you have Rue on yours?
Oh, okay, her dog.
I was like maybe I have seen photos.
- [Olivia] Oh cute.
- [Kelly] I know, I need to be cooler.
I'm gonna aim higher.
- [Olivia] Next time.
- Okay.
In honor of her album, "Guts,
we are hosting a Gutsy Hour.
Everyone in the audience has
taken a very gutsy chance
and many have Olivia to thank
for inspiring them to do so.
It's weird 'cause you don't
think you're gonna have
that kind of impact on
someone, but it really does.
Music is so magical like that
So, why "Guts"?
Why that for your title?
- Yeah, I just always loved the word.
I think it has so many
interesting meanings.
It means bravery.
Spilling your guts means
like telling everyone
your dirty little
secrets, which I feel like
is just what I do in my song.
- Yeah, amen.
- Yeah, so it's just a
really powerful word.
And I like a four letter word, you know.
- [Kelly] Me too, yeah.
- Gotta love a four letter
word every now and then.
So yeah, it just became the title.
- I love that.
I love all the separate kind of ways
you can take it as well.
- Yeah.
Will you tell us about some lyrics.
We pulled some.
- Oh yeah, sure.
- [Kelly] Do you mind?
Okay, because there's so many good ones.
In "Lacy", Olivia writes,
"And I despise my jealous
eyes and how hard"
"they fell for you."
"Yeah, I despise my rotten mind"
"and how much it worships you."
I mean, that last line.
(audience cheering)
I despise my rotten mind.
- [Olivia] Oh man.
- And how much it worships
you, I'm like that,
who has not felt?
You have a very poetic
way, kind of like Alanis,
like you have a poetic way
of like wording things,
but they're so relatable.
- Thanks.
- [Kelly] But it's so poetic.
- Wow, yeah, it's very
emo of me writing that.
- [Kelly] What were you thinking there?
- Yeah.
- I like emo, that's all right.
- Me too, me too.
- Um, I took a poetry
class actually at USC
this year, last year?
And I wrote a poem called "Lacy"
for one of the assignments.
And I really liked it, and I'm like
I'm gonna turn it into a song.
So that's sort of where
that one came from.
- When do you have time to go to college?
- I know, I know.
- [Kelly] Back that train up.
- I just took one class.
I was going to the studio some days,
and then I'd go to college
and like it was fun, it was fun, yeah.
- That is so cool.
I love that you did that.
It's always cool to
like progress and grow.
- Yeah, I always wanna
stay curious, you know.
- You've got a great song
out of it, damn, all right.
So next, in "All American
Bitch", Olivia says,
"I am". (audience cheering)
They like it.
"I am light as a feather."
"I'm as stiff as a board."
"I pay attention to things
that most people ignore."
So first of all, what do
you know about that game?
That's a game I played when I was a kid.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Did you all do that?
Light as a feather, stiff as a board?
- Have you ever done it?
Okay, did it work?
- Well, here's the thing.
There's like 15 of you around
a body with your fingers.
And you're all doing it at the same time.
That's what we did, so of
course we're all gonna lift 'em.
These are powerful fingers.
Like it was all of us,
and we're all like tiny
at the time we were playing it, yeah.
- That's true, that's true.
Well, my mom used to tell me
about doing that at sleepovers.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So that's how I knew
the light as a feather,
stiff as a board thing.
- [Kelly] That's what I did, yeah.
- And I was always fascinated by it.
I'm like, that seems impossible.
Like I need some physicist
to like explain it to me.
- Yeah.
I think it's just literally
we want it to be magical.
- [Olivia] Yeah.
- But really, it's all
of us just underneath.
- You're just forcing it really hard.
- Yeah lifting the person up.
- Yeah.
- We're like how is this happening?
- Yeah, but I always thought it was
a really interesting phrase,
and so I've been trying to get it
into a song for a long time.
So I thought it was an
interesting way to describe,
like it seems kind of
impossible, light as a feather,
stiff as a board, so I thought
it was a good way to describe
kind of the impossible standards
that are set for us as women.
So it's just kind of.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love it.
- It wrote itself, yeah.
(audience cheering)
- I love that you take something
that everybody knows too
and you twist it into something.
That's very smart.
Well, we have an audience full of people
who have been inspired by Olivia
to take some gutsy chances.
But before we hear them,
I feel like we should share ours.
I'll share, I was kind of
sharing a little bit of mine
in the break, but I get tattoos.
Well, not all of them, but a lot of them
are when not great things happen.
And I do it because I like
the reminder that I made it,
and like, it sometimes things
seem so big in your world
at that moment and you feel
like you're not gonna make it.
And then you do, and so usually
that's when I get the tattoo.
One of my favorites is
on my middle finger.
Yeah, and it says DC.
And it's 'cause somebody made me feel,
and I don't know, I hope
you never experience this
or haven't, but 'cause I
do think we've progressed
a little in this industry.
But, yeah, people can be very mean.
I mean, they can be just vicious.
And it's, you know, if
you're not successful
how they want you to be
or doing what you want,
and it's usually their shortcomings.
- [Olivia] Sure.
- And I mean, someone was so vicious.
And I was so tired of sitting in a room
where men just made me feel like (beep).
And then I was like, you know what?
Nope, I actually had
the guts to finally say,
and I was in my twenties,
you know, I started at 19.
So I was, it took a
minute, but I finally said
like you know what, I was like actually,
I think this is about you
and I think this is about.
And I just totally said
everything I've ever wanted to say
in that moment, so that's
one of my favorite tattoos.
- Wow, that's beautiful.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah, I hope you don't go through that.
But, what's one of yours?
- Oh my gosh, my gutsy story?
After that beautiful story,
mine's gonna sound so silly.
I don't know.
- No it won't, make it lighter.
- [Olivia] Okay, okay.
- I was a little heavy for day time.
(Olivia laughing)
- Okay, I'll make it day time.
I was thinking coming up
here, 'cause we're at 30 Rock,
we're in New York.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The second time I ever
performed in my career
was on SNL, and I was 18-years-old.
(audience cheering)
- Wow.
- And I was so, which is incredible.
I mean, what an honor,
but I was terrified.
- Yes, and it's so late.
- [Olivia] It's so late, yes.
- [Kelly] For a vocalist.
- Yes, and it's so live.
- [Kelly] Uh huh, yeah.
- Per the name.
And I just remember being
terrified in my dressing room
and being like, I don't know
if I deserve to be here.
This is terrifying, but I did it anyway.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that was brave of me,
but not quite as beautiful as your story.
- Whatever, don't do that.
That was very brave.
I've done SNL, it's a
little nerve wracking.
- Yeah.
- Today, I brought with me this key.
It's the key to my first
apartment that I moved into
all by myself.
And I have a disability
called Cerebral Palsy,
which makes it, it limits my mobility.
It's definitely been
nerve wracking, scary.
It can be frustrating at times.
And it makes me think about Olivia's song,
"Ballad of a Homeschooled Girl"
because in that song, she
talks about feeling insecure,
anxious after growing up sheltered.
And I definitely relate to that.
But, when I look at this key,
it makes me feel like I
made the right decision.
And I feel proud.
(audience cheering)
- All right, welcome back everybody.
I'm here with the one
and only, Olivia Rodrigo.
(audience cheering)
Olivia's album is called "Guts",
which celebrates the
gutsy choices we all make.
And that was Makayla Lee,
who just got her first
apartment in a new city.
(audience cheering)
She brought her key as a
symbol, which is so beautiful.
In fact, everyone brought
something that represents
a gutsy moment in their lives.
Before the show, we invited
a few fans, like Makayla Lee,
to share their stories on camera.
What they didn't know is that Olivia and I
were watching in another room.
So check this out.
I've been dying to have Olivia on my show.
Her new album is called "Guts",
and we're finding all these fans
that have these really
amazing gutsy stories,
and we wanna surprise them with her.
They're gonna lose their mind.
So here we go, let's do it.
- This is the studio.
You're going to be talking
straight into the camera.
- Hi, my name is Makayla Lee,
and this is my gutsy story.
Today, I brought with me this key.
It's the key to my first
apartment that I moved into
all by myself.
I have a disability called Cerebral Palsy,
which limits my mobility.
Growing up, I wasn't sure if or when
I would be able to live independently.
And it makes me think about Olivia's song,
"Ballad of a Homeschooled Girl"
because in that song, she
talks about feeling insecure,
anxious after growing up sheltered.
And I definitely relate to that.
She's helped me through
so much with her music.
- We wanted you to meet her.
- Oh my gosh! (girls yelling)
- You are amazing, you are so incredible.
I'm so happy to meet you.
- Oh, thank you.
- Thanks for coming.
- Oh my gosh.
- Thank you for having me.
- You're incredible.
- Oh, thank you so much.
- That's a big deal
getting your own apartment
in the first place.
- It's huge, it's a
terrifying thing, oh my gosh.
- Oh my gosh.
- I'm excited about this.
We wanted to surprise like
people that felt like empowered.
Like I felt empowered
by listening to "Guts".
I'm 41, and I felt empowered.
- Yes.
- It's an incredible thing to connect with
an artist like that.
- I feel empowered
listening to your story.
I think that is so incredible,
and I admire you so much for that.
That's not an easy feat.
I'm so proud of you.
Thank you so much for coming.
It was so nice to meet you.
- Thanks you so much.
- Thank you for telling your
story, it's so beautiful.
- Don't worry about the
cameras, this is very normal.
- Hi, my name is Jasmine,
and this is my gutsy item.
It is a boarding pass.
So, I met a guy through work.
We hit it off immediately.
And he met my whole family,
I met his whole family.
And I was like, this is love, this is it.
And so, we were long
distance for a minute,
and I decided, I was like,
I'm gonna spend my own money,
and I'm gonna go out and visit him.
So I go out to visit him,
and the vibes were off.
It was very weird, there's a girl there.
She's driving us around.
I'm very confused.
So I go home, I'm like I'm humiliated.
So I'm out with my girls, and
I run into the entire family.
And they're like, oh no.
You know, he actually has a girlfriend.
And I said, who?
And they said it was the girl
that was driving you around.
And I said, oh, okay, good.
So I was thinking about Olivia,
I was thinking about
her songs, and I said,
I too, want to meet his mom
and tell him her son sucks.
So that's exactly what I did.
I would say thank you for really
singing my inner teenager,
and really bringing
her out and letting me.
- Me too.
(Kelly and Olivia laughing)
- Oh my god.
- You told the craziest story, oh my gosh.
How are you?
- [Jasmine] I'm good.
- Nice to meet you.
I'm so sorry that happened to you.
- It's okay, it literally
doesn't even matter
ever, ever again.
- You're a hell of a
gutsy woman, I like it.
- You made it through.
- Um, thank you.
- You're gonna be out there with us.
We wanted to surprise you.
- We just wanted to come in,
it was so nice to meet you.
- Oh my god, you're so
amazing, you're so amazing.
This is the best day ever.
Oh god, what an actual (beep).
- Hi my name is Cassie,
and this is my gutsy story.
I brought a receipt from the
dining hall at my college
where me and my now husband, Chase,
used to always get milk shakes together.
And I really had feelings
for him, but I thought
we can't date.
I come from a religious Jewish background
and family, they wouldn't approve.
But I cannot let this person
go who cares about me so much.
Like, how can I let that go?
And I eventually told my
family, and that was probably
the gutsiest thing I've ever done.
It was the most scared
I've ever been I think.
It all worked out,
eventually they came around.
They love him now, and we just
got married this September,
two days after "Guts" was released.
Her music means so much to me.
I feel like so proud as like an older fan.
She's such a great role
model to so many people.
- You're so sweet.
That was so nice, you're so generous.
- And first of all, you
are not an older fan.
I am an older fan.
- That was the most beautiful story.
Thank you for sharing that.
- I am so honored to meet
you right now, Olivia.
- You're the coolest.
- I'm so proud of you.
You are doing such amazing things,
and I love your music so much.
So many girls out there,
people of all genders and ages,
are so lucky to have you in this industry
to see what you do for
them and your vulnerability
and your passion, and
I'm just like so honored
to tell you this.
- You are too kind.
- And you are so eloquent.
I'm never like that when
I meet people I love.
- Congrats on your wedding.
- Thank you so much.
- [Cassie] Thank you.
- Would you like a picture?
- I would love a pictures so much.
- Yeah, we have to take
a picture to show him.
- I'm gonna let her get one alone.
That way you don't have to crop me.
(people laughing)
Yeah, Jasmine, Makayla, and Cassie
are all here today, everybody.
(audience cheering)
So Makayla, Makayla I'm
gonna start with you.
So, what were you thinking when
she tapped on your shoulder?
- Oh my gosh, so shocked, so surprised.
I was like, what's going on?
I'm still in shock.
And I was telling these lovely people that
I'm not crying right now,
but probably when I go home
I'll like listen to "Guts" and cry because
even before "Guts" came
out, like "Sour" helped me
through my first heartbreak.
And your vulnerability
allows me to be vulnerable,
so thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
- So well spoken.
Ah, what are you thoughts?
I imagine like with this
album, you've had so many fans
come up to you and tell you
kind of their gutsy moments.
- Yeah.
- Like what does that mean for you?
Like how does that affect you?
- It's so incredible.
I mean, also when I put
out "Sour", it was kind of
pandemic era, so I didn't
really get to actually interact
with people who were
listening to the music.
- [Kelly] Oh weird, right.
- So it's really special
to get to meet you guys
and hear your stories.
I love it so much, thank
you guys for coming.
It means the world to me.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Well, Olivia's six-time
Grammy nominated album,
that's what I said,
six-time, "Guts" is available
right now wherever you get your music.
You gotta get it, it's so good.